bringing a pet home for a child should
be a joyous occasion but it's turned to
heartache for animal lovers caught up in
the hong kong government's latest
anti-covert crackdown a hamster car
anyone who bought hamsters recently has
been ordered to hand them over to the
health workers
i didn't think of not turning them in
the first thing i did was to get myself
tested and to get my whole family tested
but after some consideration there were
so many unknowns so this was the only
thing we could really do
an increase in curvid 19 infections was
traced back to this pet shop where 11
hamsters tested positive for the virus
since then health workers have been
visiting other pet shops in the
territory to enforce the curl
and the government isn't only targeting
animals
anyone who recently entered the shops
will have to go into quarantine for
three weeks
whether they had direct contact with the
hamsters or not
but most scientists say it's extremely
rare for the virus to be transmitted
from pets to people
we need to remember that
you know millions of people around the
world have been infected by
sars cove ii
millions of people around the world have
pets and there have been no cases
proven of pets transmitting infection to
other humans
dozens of shops have been forced to
close and animal importers have been
ordered to suspend trade
the government says it doesn't have the
capacity to test every hamster in hong
kong
but the cull will cut transmission
chains
barbara angopa al jazeera